so last time actually we talked a little
bit about the difference between open
games and closed games and how you
should react to each this game very
closed game how many people feel more
comfortable in open positions in
general okay that makes a lot of sense
we've got a six-year-old in the audience
and usually younger players do prefer
the open positions cuz know that why is
open position preferable usually to
people who are very
young yes in open positions are are a
lot of tactics what defines open
positions are lots of lines open like by
pawns getting traded off the board it's
really the only way to open lines right
and therefore there's a lot of contact
between the pieces and a lot of tactics
so Clos games buy contracts a lot of
maneuvering and a lot of times uh more
positional players sometimes more mature
prefer that though there are some
exceptions these days it seems like um
it kind of can go both ways easily so
the game started with a perk opening and
white played a little bit strangely you
were white in this game right so were
you familiar with the perk opening or
never play you never played against
what's your rating uh about 1400 okay
because I thought you played very well
in this game played well over 4300
actually the part of the game where you
played the wor weakest in a way the end
well that the very end obviously cuz
that's what made you lose spoiler alert
sorry guys so darn it well but um it
wasn't just the uh that part it was it
was the uh the very beginning was it
it's not like it was like so high stakes
the fact that you played the beginning
poorly didn't really affect your
position that drastically that's the
weird thing about the opening a lot of
times unless you're playing a super
super sharp opening you can kind of go
off on your own and it's it's not like
it's going to change the evaluation from
winning to lost it's just kind of a tip
of a hat to your opponent that you
haven't studied the
opening that's about it so keep it in
perspective that's the important thing a
lot of people they try to get this
airtight opening repertoire which is
awesome but keeping in perspective that
you opponent differs and you don't know
what to do it really you can rely on
your natural chess talent and you'll be
okay the worst thing you can do is try
to have an airtight opening repertoire
then things don't go according to plan
and you panic and get really upset and
play
badly so and I do have students like
that and I'm like yeah for you maybe you
just shouldn't study the opening at all
uh anyway in this position white played
Bishop to D3 um I just think that that
move I mean I saw a few people playing
in a database but it strikes me as a bit
strange
um what do you think some more common
developing systems in this position are
first of All Black's move is a little
bit unusual normally when black plays
this line how do they continue their
development
here yes they they play G6 and they F
Kettle their bishop and they castle and
often they play Knight bd7 later but
usually the first order of business is
developing this bishop to the G7
Square well yeah there are some other
possibilities like E5 is sometimes
played I believe it's kind of weird it
allows an end game right
away um Knight bd7 is definitely
plausible it's just a a little bit less
common um so I don't blame you for not
knowing the opening here but this is
more about opening principles it's not
just about knowing the opening where I
went yeah just going General guidin yeah
you just went on General guidelines it's
just that Bishop D3 is not my favorite
move here of all because of a couple
things why do you guys think I don't
like Bishop D3 that
much okay Julian said The Bishop's just
protecting E4 Arin it blocks the defense
of the D pawn it blocks defense of the D
Pawn that might become relevant later
yeah right okay if they fan Kettle this
bishop then you're just GNA be as we say
biting on granite that Bishop is just
not doing anything if that pawn gets
developed to G6 thanks
so I would prefer either one or the
other like either just go go for it Play
Bishop C4 be very aggressive
or um Play Bishop E2 ultimately and be
very quiet and give your your your uh
yourself some space um the Knight could
go to F3 and then you could play Bishop
E2 the the other thing I don't like
about Bishop D3 for what it's worth is
that when when they play C5 later
sometimes your Bishop gets targeted so
certainly not a terrible move but just
seems a little bit maybe slightly off um
and then your opponent played E5 and
yeah D5 this just strikes me as
unpleasant for white I have some
experience and positions where I've
gotten like kind of found myself in
positions like this and I really don't
like the fact that my pawns are like
this listen I don't play D4 openings I
play E4 so normally when we have this
type of structure I'm always like well
it would be nice if I was an actual D4
player and my Pawn was on C4 so it
actually have something going on the
queen side right because now it's like I
it looks like kind of maybe I should
have something on the queen side but I
don't really have much
momentum and then on the flip side black
kind of has a clear plan here even
though it's early to say that there's
something that strikes me about this
position that black might be able to
develop um does anybody see what I mean
I know it's a little bit in the future
but what type of break might black try
to play later in the
game yes F5 could come into play F5 in
conjunction with C6 and all of this
happened and it's not worse for white
but it's just a little bit less Pleasant
for white I find that White's plans are
harder to kind of concoct
here I mean unless you want to like try
to play for F4 or something I don't
know I might go for that just cuz I
don't really like I I want to get some
play and I feel if I just play standard
like Knight F3 castle like I don't
really know what I'm doing with my pawns
I might just try to play for F4
immediately
here should take what's that should well
he could take on F4 but then I get to
take with the bishop and this is a
little bit of like an unusual formation
but seems okay to for me to White I
prefer that than developing the Knight
first and not really having a
plan now I can play Knight F3 and castle
and at least I have more space and kind
of like a clear idea Queen D2 Rook E1
it's a little bit unusual normally this
bishop would be over here and then I
wouldn't like it as much for white
because you would have a lot of play on
the diagonal and you Rook e eight but
because your Bishop is on this passive
Square E7 I'm kind of feeling this you
know especially it's nice the Knight
can't come to G4 and do this
thingy which would also be effective
because that's a strong Square
here a question in the back wonder about
planning to Castle Queen side at this
point um oh if if we got this if we
achieve this position it's very
dangerous to Castle Queen side I I would
probably be more inclined in this
specific situation to just play Knight
F3 and Castle King side and hope to get
an attack on the king side but I don't
think your idea is out of the question I
just feel like we might be Lo losing
more than we gain here cuz now when they
play for like a C6
idea they're opening up lines against
our King
whereas it's I mean I guess I guess if
they if you if they take here you open
up this bishop so that's kind of nice
but other than that it seems like your
king is much less safe here than it was
over here but what his castling Queen
side really open for you I mean you want
to play H4 H5
H6 I don't really think so think in this
position it's about the pawn storm you
know but it's definitely not a bad idea
it it just kind of strikes me maybe not
the perfect fit for this
position so
anyway uh that's kind of interesting um
you played Knight
F3 you played C6 and now after castle
Yeah and see this is the thing after C6
it's a bit annoying because you you
didn't really want to take on C6 and
give him the center control and The Rook
on B8 so you just castled and it's it's
funny because this is an example of
position that um computer analysis will
not be particularly helpful for
her
because I think that this position is
fine for white but I personally think
it's unpleasant to play for white like I
think the advantage if black has an
advantage it's granted it's got to be a
relatively small Advantage objectively
but I think from a POS positional point
of view it's more much more fun for
black why what makes this position more
fun for
black and where is Black's going to do
what he going to play F5 F4 or F5 you
know maybe bishop F6 E4 Knight E5 that
kind of thing right so to me and and
then there's also the psychological
element that you're white and you're a
bit on the defensive of course that
shouldn't be relevant but somehow it
feels like this feels like even more
negative to me to have to search for a
plan here because I'm white and I feel
like I should have some kind of edge
right um anyway so your opponent did
play F5 your oppon by the way is about
2,200
okay um Alex Mara
yeah and you're um you're Kevin is that
right Jason Jason okay Jason great and
you're over 2,000 as well okay great so
what do you think about all this you're
high rated player do you do you agree
with a lot of what I'm saying or do you
disagree with
something so
what
so you so Jason who's an expert in the
audience um also thinks that black is
better how would you have played
differently for white to would you have
done something different what kind of
configuration would you have chosen in
the opening do you have a favorite
configuration against the
perk not really oh you don't play
E4 you play
D4 okay well you play D4 so there you go
and Julian you play E4 right I play
everything okay I play Everything nice
all right
so and by the way um what was your name
in the back who suggested castle and que
inside Kevin there are a lot of good
lines in the perk where you Castle Queen
side it's just a lot of times those are
ones where you haven't made an exchange
on D5 so you kind kind of have a little
bit more control over the position
there's not that open C file but you can
do a kind of English attack against the
perk sometimes um but note that that's
usually when your opponent fian ketto is
your Bishop which gives you more to chew
on right cuz if your opponent being
Kettle is their bishop and you Castle
Queens side you can play like H4 H5 and
attack right whereas when their pawns
are more pristine on H7 and
G7 you're not really uh hitting anything
if you get your Pawn to H6 they can play
G6 right that make
sense so um you slid your Bishop back to
F1 and now um Marlo is not here at the
moment he played a move he played a very
aggressive move here she just start Play
G5
immediately uh as they say in poker I'm
kind of a knit so I I probably wouldn't
have even played that here I would have
just played um I would have just tried
to nurse my advantage in another way any
other
ideas
Julian I didn't even think of that I I'm
I'm kind of more concerned of trying to
develop here a little
bit I just want to play in this I feel
like my Center is strong I don't really
feel like I need to play G5 although G5
might be a very good move I just think
there's other ways if for some reason
and you don't have the uh feeling that
you want to play G5 because of your king
safety you could I think get a nice
position here and play a little bit more
conservatively I any any plans come to
mind
Julian B B that's an interesting plan so
you want to play Knight F6 Bishop D7
Bishop E8 the thing is eventually there
might be a knight G5 so you're going to
have to take a break and play H6 for
sure right um if this Knight could come
to G5 here that would be pretty sweet
actually even if you play Queen E8 I
think we could also consider that right
away um in general it's something you
should watch out
for uh I was just thinking also black
could just play like Bishop F6 and you
know maybe E4 Knight C5 just kind of
like play the position more in the
center and less in like trying to just
like attack attack attack but I like uh
I like the way G5 turned out so um kudos
to marer for being very creative and
aggressive you know even though his
King's here
be careful about doing that
but now King
H1 be just fine okay well
C4 I'd probably just play C4 and try to
get something going on my own
here King H1 was what you was what you
played yeah I know you I don't but
because you're but you're getting like
just very defensive
Andie
so he play
G
Allie so he's joking the uh the white
player in this position is joking that
um he was studying a lot of steets at
the time and wanted to move all of his
pieces backwards so yeah the the defense
here seems very passive I'm not sure
it's totally necessary but
okay now you're getting aggressive
attack his Rook
now you played F3 so yeah so you're
trying to justify this Knight on G1
maybe it'll get back out at some point
soon see the uh light of day
again so he attacked you and now you
retreated and then um yeah I was
thinking he might just try to play G3
here right away but instead he tried to
build up with
H5 how many people in this position um
like Black's
position how many people think maybe
black has overextended and gone too far
with his idea no
anyone you wait did you have your hand
up you had your hand up both
times he likes the position for black
but he thinks it's overx okay understand
all right yeah I guess that is possible
for both both things to be true you
could like a position that's not even
good
right um but here uh White played Bishop
D3 so you're now you're now you're
redeveloping your pieces
um you're redeveloping your pieces you
played Bishop D3 earlier in the game and
then you played Bishop F1 and now you're
playing back to D3 and yet at this point
this is a very logical move you're
attacking
F5 so I'm just I'm just teasing you I
actually do not think that is a bad move
at all it's a good move so now your
position is starting to look a little
bit more like it makes sense your
opponent played Queen G8 you played
F4 I'm going to go through some of this
quick because this game is just
incredibly long and it starts to get
tactical like another 10 moves from
now and now um again I thought maybe
your opponent would play g3 at some
point like just try to break
through um and then in this position
what might you try for black
Air don't call
out
Julian I don't know if that's going to
quite work think you have a more um I do
think you can sacrifice here
but
mm- yeah Orin D3 um Rook E3 is a cool
idea but the Rook kind of wanted to
chill here I was thinking that um black
could just play H4 in this position
because now if the Knight were to take
on D3 what would happen arjin what do
you think would happen
here do you think you whenever you have
a choice between captures I think it's
always good to take a deep Long look at
it right so do you play when when you
play your chess games do you play really
quickly or do you play more on the
slower side I usually play quickly you
usually play pretty quickly okay so one
one sign that you should slow down is
when you have a few different ways to
capture because that's exactly the point
where it's a Make It or Break It If you
find the right capture you might be
winning if you find the weaker capture
it might be like whatever me or drawish
so this is exactly where you should
think now which one is better in
why and this come is true for all levels
I mean even up to the highest levels it
seems that a lot of mistakes are made in
moments of capture so it's something
that we should all be very aware of so
yes I'm sure um taking with the pawn you
understand why it's very strong we're
just we're just threatening check Maiden
too
right see that we're threatening Queen
to H7 followed by Queen to H2 mate and
as typical in a lot of these types of
Kings Indian like structures this wasn't
a Kings Indian but it's starting to
resemble one right you're a D4 player so
you play on the white side of this right
yeah and now um this is just Unstoppable
right I mean try to stop
it Bishop D3 Bishop D3 yeah you can't
even play um I'm sorry Queen H7 yeah you
can't even play Bishop E2 because it's
still madeen into
right so so Julian is suggesting Bishop
D3 just so that you can survive for
another moment
right and now if uh Queen H2 King F1
Queen H1 King E2 Queen G2 check at least
you can run away to E3 right but of
course uh maid is imminent there
actually there's maid on F2 right you
guys see that
so so Queen H2 King F1 Queen H1 King E2
Queen takes G2 King E3 and then Queen
F2 great it's good to try to visualize
things before they actually happen
because that's what it takes to uh get
to the next level of course you can also
win by taking
this win you don't exactly yeah you
never know like uh I always think it's
important to find the quickest win
because some of you guys play game 29
game 30 and in those tournaments you
know if you find uh the speedier win
you're you might win instead of of
choking and when you had two minutes on
your clock and losing so it's
important all right so um that would
have been one interesting idea but Mara
plays this game very patiently so he you
know I keep looking at him I'm like play
get there get there crash
through if he pushed my idea was to push
my so you were just going to play yeah I
think that's probably why he didn't do
it although the thing is I think he can
also we're here I soon yeah right yeah I
think the thing is here you can also try
to um
sacrifice yeah that's what I was
thinking Knight G4 that maybe he could
play this because this just looks very
it looks very dangerous to take this
right I mean this Rook H6
or Rook H6 or queen H7 are unstoppable
and you're just G to have to sacrifice
your knight and I'm going to crash
through right my doesn't have to take
okay so if you don't take um you you
it's going to be a little tricky for you
to stop Knight F2 I guess you were
thinking Bishop E3
maybe he can play Bishop
C3 no Bishop E3 seems like the best
choice but then well I don't know if
this is good no because this just wins
yeah this actually well this is just
like we're just going to win a night
here right that Knight on on G1 look
what happened see if your King on E1 you
take so okay so yeah that this but I
don't know
think it but but otherwise how are you
defending F2 because I'm it's actually a
mate threat right isn't that kind of
cool I haven't seen too many mates like
that so like if you move your queen away
like actually like Knight F2 is
just H chest bace is broken it can't
move
anymore there a Checkmate so you can't
you can't stop I think the fact that
it's both Checkmate and it's threatening
to um you know Fork the king and the
queen right so I guess you would have to
play rookie two or something here and
then sacrifice The
Exchange something like this but that
now we've also reopened our our file so
it seems pretty
good
yeah good ey Julian though you saw like
that's what I I was I was I was actually
going to make that a little quiz like
what does black do here but you had
already seen it
so but this kind of thing is really um
par for the course for people who play
the Kings Indian defense is black um
it's these types of tactics are very
typical anyway um Alex played H4
instead and now you played Bishop to C3
to try to kind of like pin down his
Knight because the Knight was wrecking
so much havoc in those other
variations um so he he got out of it
with King
H7 okay Rook C1 B6 so yeah Alex is just
like kind of biting his time before he
tries to do anything anything too nasty
to you and now he you play Knight D4
trying to get your knight in play that
makes
sense Rook
E8 so now this is a this is a good move
Knight H5 it looks like a strong idea
trying toh attack your
pawn and get things going on the H file
so you've successfully kind of closed
down the possibility of him opening up
the G file so now he's trying to open up
the H
file and now he's REM maneuvering all of
his pieces I think he's trying to get
like I mean it's just it's just amazing
the Maneuvers in this
game uh so here what do you think black
tried you
know arson sacrifice a night that where
you have multiple places to sacrifice a
night okay so you could try Knight takes
G3 um and then I think I think that
maror was thinking here that if Knight
takes
G3 Rook G3 The Rook would get a little
bit closer to help the defense right
because for instance if Queen H5
threatening you know Queen H1 and Rook
H2 and um fun stuff like that now the uh
The Rook is kind of participating in the
defense right like it could go Rook G2
and now if you play Queen H1 King F2
Bishop H4
check seems like maybe
we're hanging on a little bit here right
does that make sense so instead and I
and actually white did a good job of you
you play great defense and you hang on
for a while with the move that he did
play but I think the move that he played
Knight takes F4 Pawn F4 now after Queen
H5
uh this might be a little bit trickier
to defend
right
so just because you're just because
you're you're now threatening
directly Queen H1 check King F2 and
Bishop H4 check which will be kind of
nasty like let's just say let's just see
for the sake of argument how ugly this
is so now we have a couple choices right
like I said earlier whenever you have
these moments you want to look at all
your choices so you could play Rook H2
check or you could play Bishop H4
check if you play Bishop
H4 and then your Rook is is left out of
the party right so you want to play Rook
H2 check first Bishop G2 no good because
we can take it so king must drop back to
E1 and now
what Arin yeah Bishop H4 now Bishop H4
so this is an example of what we call in
chest what is this an example of move
order right you know we need to make
sure that we find the right move order
of our checks and our
captures so
okay so obviously B4 wasn't play that
was just one of those dummy moves we
make to uh illustrate a point so what
kind of defensive ideas do you do you
have here for white to not get uh just
resigns next move Julian maybe you can
play rookie2
K but also here I want to play Rook h
okay so you're you're thinking wait you
want to play rookie H3 here yeah I think
you're down too much material to get
away with that cuz he hasn't sacrificed
enough like if you play rookie H
what he hasn't sacrificed enough enough
I think to for you to get away with this
like what the material would be uh you'd
be down in exchange right yeah oh so you
just think that's the best you can do
yeah but
maybe yeah this uh I don't think this is
going to work out too well because
you're actually you're actually down an
exchange and a pawn right so it's not
enough of a
try Rook ag2 here do I have let's see I
was thinking I might have some some
tactical ways here
to yeah I think I might be able to play
like Rook C8 maybe Target you then I
take
H3 well right yeah I'm trying to take on
C4 and you're trying to take on
F5 no you don't yeah Bishop
takes yeah yeah maybe you will win the
pawn back it's possible I think I should
be able to find some find something
useful to do with my time though like
maybe check you and then um you know if
you go back to the
corner what's
that well if you go to F2 I'm coming in
with my Bishop too it just looks kind of
nasty again I'm coming with my Bishop to
H4
and if you come come to E3 now I get to
put my Rook on
G3 yeah um doesn't look it's not looking
good though because if you play King E2
then I'm going to at least win the F4
Pawn which should be even stronger than
the other pawns that I was winning and
regardless I'm up in exchange so uh it
looks like looks like things are kind of
really going my way there I don't think
you're desperate enough in this position
to do that it's good to look at stuff
like that if your opponent sacrificed
enough material you want to look at
those simplifying variations at trade
Queen it's an Instinct but here I think
you're better off trying to weather the
storm um there are two reasonable
options um you play Bishop G2 to try to
kind of Shield the checks a little bit
any other ways to try to Shield yourself
here as as
white Rook E2 but what does even better
better better job of like shielding
you arson Queen
E2 not Queen E2
Julian saying that here is just Rook
H2 also Bishop H well also Bishop H4
yeah so uh what else here Bishop G2
makes sense I also think Rook G Rook G2
also the the famous fan Kettle Rook that
also makes us uh gives us a little bit
of space because the Rook stops The Rook
H2 check which is really convenient
right and if Bishop H4 check King E2 and
somehow it's hard for you to get more
pieces into the game
right yeah actually before I wanted to
bop and now if Rook H2 here uh I was
thinking maybe just put the other Rook
on
G3 and then if then you have Bishop H4
but now you know we we can consider we
can consider like just giving back some
material because we're still we still
got two pieces for a rock
right and it doesn't seem like you have
any checks or even any ways to threaten
check so it seems like we're relatively
safe
here well let's uh keep going to the
game because it gets kind of interesting
I think I like I like Rook G2 because it
Shields us a a lot I we can take a brief
look at rookie too but it just the other
the other I oh you want to play the
other Rook
there and you just want to try to get in
in here as well but I'm worried about
you giving up this
square if you play that move I think I
just play
Bishop yeah you could try
that and I'm going to try to go after
the F4 Pawn
now yeah you pretty much have to play
Queen
D2 yeah it's another possibility I think
maybe I missed something there though I
don't know if I don't know if I really
want to play G3 I was just thinking
about it because if I don't have
something concrete after G3 I probably
want to leave it here play G3 I think I
prefer maybe just playing Queen to H1
and seeing how this
goes it looks it's looking kind of
promising um but yeah it's it's kind of
I just think the doesn't look like your
king is as shielded in this variation at
all so and also like we could we at some
moment we can maybe consider playing for
our G3 move so anyway uh I I think Rook
G2 looks like a good defensive option
you play Bishop to
G2 and then he played Queen H2 check and
the thing with this one is that it does
uh give back the pawn immediately on F4
which is kind of annoying cuz that opens
up another extra line against your king
yeah also them all and the problem with
the problem also is that here he's got
this extra idea to do
what what can black do here to try to
gain some material immediate material
back if he wants
to Bishop G5 yeah you black can try
Bishop
G5 and the work on E three can't be
protected so you you have to try to drop
the exchange right away and white black
doesn't even need to take it immediately
he could start off start off with
something like Rook H2 right so that
might have been a better try for him he
played G3 immediately and actually here
you play Queen F1 again you have this
instinct to trade Queens which is a
great instinct when you're getting
attacked that's great but it didn't work
out as well for you um after Queen F1 he
had a good idea here what do you think
maybe black should have tried
here what did he do I can't remember
what he did but I thought he had some
something kind of good
here thing is your pawns are very strong
as black
right black has very strong pawns six of
them against your four so even though
he's technically down a piece for two
pawns here um if he can get even a
little bit of material back he might be
in a very good position
indeed or Bishop G yeah Queen G4 I think
that is what he did he did do queen G4
check followed by Bishop G5 but what
about Bishop G5
immediately now if Queen takes F4 Bishop
takes F4 what are we
threatening well we're we're threatening
Bishop takes E3 but we're actually
threatening something even stronger that
will uh could you raise your hand um
we're actually threatening something
even stronger that would just make white
basically resign instantly yes Rook H2
here would just make white resign
because if you like say another let's
play that our traditional dummy move I
keep making the same dummy move B4 um if
B4 Rook
H2 and now if white plays King F1 Bishop
takes Rook right so we win the whole
Rook not the exchange
and there's nothing you can do about it
this is actually a pretty aesthetic
example
of White's Rook just being rather
checkmated
right so that would be kind of a cool
way for him to have played uh I think
you I think you had the right idea
trying to get your queen to the defense
but maybe a better execution would have
been Queen E1 just going after this Pawn
cuz notice now you've kind of got Rook
H2 held at Bay because you can just take
on
G3 right Bish over I can
take yeah you can take on you can take
on G3 with your Rook
or or could you also take with your
queen I think you can also just take
with your
queen because because now now you've got
this position and you've got the uh the
two pieces for the rook and the pawn
but it looks like you got a nice little
blockade yeah if you take with the Rook
let's see is that also okay or does this
black have something good here I think
the problem here is black can now play
this and instead of yeah that that looks
like a stronger move CU instead of just
winning the exchange I think he's going
to win the um the whole shebang
here similar to the variation we were
just looking at so you got to take with
the
queen and this looks like a a good Sav
being attempt
right so
instead he played oh you play Queen F1
and he played Queen G4
check and then he play Bishop
G5 and now you played Rook
E2 and he played Bishop
F6 played Rook D2 E3 Rook D3 F4 wow
those pawns are really coming at you huh
luckily you've got the light square is
blockaded so you play Queen F3 it seems
like you're pretty enthusiastic about
trading Queens in this
position and now yeah um he could have
tried
taking um it looked kind of promising
for black just CU you're you just almost
can't make any moves right on said he
wanted to keep Queens on the board which
is underst animal and then you played
Knight to E6 you know there a move we
talked about earlier and it kind of
you've been you've been patient and and
like not playing it all game but you
finally got your chance so you decided
to take it and then after Bishop
E6 right you want to just kind of like
open lines up against his King which
makes a lot of sense and that's
something you also see happening a
decent amount in the king's Indian
defense that if black kind of gets too
Hog Wild with his attack sometimes um
white will once they sty it they'll get
their own attack going on in the center
of the queen ey so you do especially
since their King is usually rather
exposed like in this
example but uh okay so 96 and now here
is where we reached a point where you
made a big error after playing like some
really Admiral defense against a player
of 600 points higher rated right you
said you were, 1400 at the time is that
1300 so seven or 800 points now that's
that's admirable because a lot of people
crack against players that are that high
rated right so this is a good example of
how you should I I'm not a believer that
you shouldn't look at your opponent's
rating I think that's kind of
unrealistic a lot of times you're going
to find out one way or the other but you
certainly should not have it let it
affect your play very much right you
should still play the same aggressive
chess that you would play regardless and
if you're playing a low rated player the
same applies you shouldn't like try to
play like really really aggressive moves
all the time just CU they're lower rated
A lot of times those solid moves are
going to really be the ones that make
them crack I mean so many times I've
played in simultaneous exhibitions where
I play a lot of we players and sometimes
I start to get worried because after the
openings everybody seems to be playing
so well and like I'm not like winning
any games quickly but what happens is
like after they get out of the opening
and you just play a few solid moves they
start to feel this pressure like I don't
know what to do right so I think on both
angles whether you're playing weaker or
stronger for the most part try to play
the board there's going to be some very
small exceptions in certain cases but
not why focus on the exceptions right
focus on the fact that 95% of the time
you play exactly the same stronger or
weaker anyway here uh this is the moment
where you cracked and like I said
happens so much when there are different
types of captures and checks in a
position that's when strong players weak
players and everything in between make a
lot of Errors a larger than normal error
rate um so Queen E4 check was what was
played and why is this move so
bad
black to
move what's that why is Bishop F5 such a
good
move book yes and basically you just do
the math like we've lost a piece in in
this uh exchange right because this was
the piece that we were supposed to
recapture so now instead they get our
rook and we get their so we traded Rooks
but we ended up netting an extra piece
right as black and so this this position
is now dead lost right
right I think was there any more play or
you resigned in this position I
didn't why oh I think why is not going
forward oh maybe I didn't have any more
moves in my score sheet or I thought it
was yeah I probably stopped yeah yeah
you might have stopped you might have
stop notating or maybe it was ineligible
after this point or something but uh
instead here what else can you
do yeah I had the right idea because I
put it through the computer
but so instead you could just do some
like normal like d takes C6 and
then
here just try to start getting your
Rooks into play something like that yeah
and and it's not entirely clear it looks
like it's hard for you to get this Rook
into play is the problem right right but
certainly you're not resigning I don't
know what's going on here how do I get
this guy into
play I don't think I can I think I just
like hang tough here
right and hope and kind just kind of set
up like a more of a fortress type
situation I would I would rather not
trade off that Rook if I
could but yeah so there would have been
a lot of play left here so good game
very interesting game you know you can
really learn a lot from it it seems like
you played a lot better than 1300 in
this game so good
job
m